more
on this Christian nationalism this
bigotry run amok and using the Bible to
justify their bigotry
I played for you yesterday
a clip of Pastor Andrew Brunson
at the national gathering for prayer and
repentance you know where Kevin McCarthy
prayed over a bunch of Congress people
who are literally crying and weeping for
forgiveness about the evils of America
and there's a line in there
that Brunson uses talking about a
millstone
a scripture in the Bible Matthew
chapter 18 I think
where Jesus says something a woman to
pair of phrase not much of a Jesus quota
but get you
like me
it's something about that it's
it's utter if you cause a child to sin
or fall away from from following Jesus
it's better to have a millstone a
massive rock that would Mill wheat
tied around your neck and have you
thrown to the Bottom of the Sea
execution
that it's better for that to happen than
for you to cause a child to stray from
Christ
and Brunson used that line
and to prove more evidence more points
about Christian nationalism being
dangerous and this spiritual warfare
element and melding politics and
religion there's a congressman a state
legislator
in Oklahoma who just is introducing the
millstone Act
and I want to read about that but
firstly I'll give you the Refresher
on Brunson and his prayer at the
national gathering for prayer and
repentance
I believe that we are in danger of
judgment as a nation especially because
we have become the primary corrupter of
the world
and particularly of Youth and children
our government and corporations
increasingly March under the rainbow
flag
we bully weaker and poorer countries to
come under that flag our University's
train millions of foreign students who
returned to their countries with this
ideology our social media and
entertainment companies make it
attractive they promote they normalize
celebrate immorality
and there's no escaping them as a
blanket the world
they're Godly mothers and fathers around
the world who fear our influence and
sometimes when I'm in a foreign country
I want to fall on my knees and repent
for what we are doing to these countries
to these people
Jesus said woe to the ones to the one
who causes others to sin
and he underlines us especially in
relation to the young whoever causes one
of these little ones to sin it would be
better for him if a millstone were hung
around his neck and he were drowned in
the depth of the sea
he's low-key in a milk-toast way talking
about execution
and again you may think he's a fringe
character you might think he's a nobody
you've never heard of
you might think he has no power other
than the influence of a congregation
but he influences people who do have a
say
the Congress people in that room who
prayed with him and over him
and people like this legislator
in Oklahoma
David Bullard
I'm going to read a little bit from
Andrew Seidel wrote this piece talking
about this and I think it's poignant and
I hope
that it will illuminate some things for
you if you are not quite on board with
exactly how dangerous and present this
threat is
uh the article here Christian
nationalist legislator introduces
anti-trans Millstone act suggesting
biblical retribution
a Biblical death sentence in America in
2023 a legislator has proposed the
millstone act which he openly confesses
quote was named in reference to Matthew
18 6 but whoever causes one of these
little ones who believe in me to sin it
is better for him to have a heavy
Millstone be hung around his neck and
that he be drowned in the depths of the
sea
America embraced the separation of
church and state as a core fundamental
value precisely to prevent religious
despots from abusing government power to
impose their personal religion on all of
us but Oklahoma State Senator David
Bullard is a Christian nationalist out
to make Oklahoma into a Christian State
forged in the fires of Oklahoma State
Senator David bullard's violent
Christian imagery this bill is one of a
horde of anti-trans bills sweeping our
country bullard's Bill purports to
protect children while threatening
medical professionals it declares a
state of emergency and bans gender
affirming care in the name of bullard's
God as with other such bills it
dehumanizes and demonizes trans people
unlike other bills Bullard christened
his with a Biblical name that threatens
that promises violence and death
again
this is mainstreaming and you may live
in California or New York or
Massachusetts or here in Washington DC
and you think ah I live in a liberal
Library area this will never happen
but there are hundreds of millions of
Americans who live in red States who are
under the thumb of despots just like
this if you think there are no Democrats
in Oklahoma who will be under the thumb
of this you're wrong if you don't think
there's millions of Democrats in Texas
where they will copy this
you're wrong Christian nationalist
politicians have almost nothing to offer
their constituents other than the bitter
sectarianism of Christian nationalism
the Republican Takeover in Congress
which is focused on Petty retribution
pointless and performative
investigations and possibly cratering
the global economy proves the point
instead of doing good such politicians
seek to strip women and minorities of
every protection support Aid assistance
and basic dignity and then call
themselves pro-life
they'll gladly enact policies that
dramatically increase infant mortality
and thrust millions of children into
poverty while claiming to care about
Children's Health they fetishize their
guns muellishly clutching the
instruments of the leading cause of
death for America's children with an
unrivaled passion they rail against
life-saving vaccines and masks and the
scientific consensus behind them while
the covet pandemic is also among the top
10 killers of our children and then
brimming with arrogance and utterly
lacking self-knowledge they have the
gall to propose legislation that amounts
to a death threat against those who
would harm children another line from
The Book of Matthew comes to mind you
hypocrite first take the plank out of
your own eye
Andrew Seidel
and if you think it's just Fringe it's
just a state guy he doesn't really have
much influence or power over the rest of
us
think again because Matt Walsh just
yesterday
the daily wires Matt Walsh Ben Shapiro's
little bearded lap dog
called for the execution of doctors
who provide gender affirming care
Trump also says as he goes on to say
that the that he would direct the
Department of Justice to investigate
hospitals pharmaceutical companies uh
doctors to find out if they've been
involved in a cover-up of the horrific
long-term side effects uh and of gender
transition drugs and surgeries and the
answer of course is that yes they have
been covering those things up as any
genuine and thorough investigation will
clearly show which is why the next step
under a trump Administration or any
Republican Administration should be to
arrest the culprits the um hundreds and
hundreds of them if not thousands of
them and throw them in federal prison
now this can be a matter of simple fines
and financial penalties I mean that
should be part of it
but uh the only real recourse here the
only semblance of Justice would be
prison sentence is very long ones
now if it were up to me we you know we'd
go further than that as far as I'm
concerned mutilating and castrating
children should be legally considered a
capital crime and it should earn the
prescribed penalty for such crimes but
if we can't have that then prison will
have to suffice
this is where we are in America in 2023.
so I would assume there are many out of
you out there who are organizers who are
activists who care about the direction
that our country is taking
and this isn't just about budget battles
we are this is not hyperbolic we are in
it for the fight for the soul of our
nation are we a nation of equality and
acceptance and diversity
or are we a country of white Christian
nationalism and oppression
that's the question
and are you ready
because it's only going to get worse
before it gets better
I'd love to have you subscribe to my
YouTube channel dollar more daily here
on YouTube you can find my podcast
anywhere podcasts are found it's called
I doubt it with my lovely talented and
scholarly co-host Brittany page and of
course you can follow me on social media
and tell me how wrong I am there I am at
dollymore on Twitter tick tock and
Instagram